cuál es la importancia de esta
ratificación a qué se está
comprometiendo colombia
colombia tiene un problema muy grave de
asesinato de líderes ambientales y de
poca transparencia en el desarrollo de
proyectos entonces el acuerdo de escazú
procura garantizar el acceso a la
información la participación pública el
acceso a la justicia a los defensores
ambientales la protección a los
defensores entonces esta aprobación pues
es un mensaje muy claro del nuevo
congreso respecto a la necesidad de
proteger a esos defensores y de diseñar
estrategias adecuadas para que el país
pueda
garantizar un ambiente sano para
garantizar un derecho que tienen las
comunidades de acuerdo con el principio
de naciones unidas-
establecido en río bueno este pacto fue
promovido por el actual presidente iván
duque pero su bancada en el congreso no
quiso aprobarlo cuáles eran las razones
de su oposición
y
una una carta una comunicación del
consejo gremial que es la asociación de
empresarios de colombia en una
interpretación que nos pareció insólita
las organizaciones sociales y
ambientales que planteaban básicamente
que la ratificación del acuerdo de
descanso iba en posibilitar el
desarrollo de cualquier proyecto lo que
se pretende no es que no se puedan
desarrollar proyectos sino que los
proyectos se hagan
discutiendo con las comunidades qué es
lo que se pretende hacer no imponiendo
los proyectos en las regiones y mucho
menos generando amenazas que vengan de
los actores que vengan pongan en riesgo
a las personas que están interesadas en
saber sobre los proyectos
esa comunicación que salió de algunos
gremios del país generó una vez el
gobierno nacional bajó mucho la
disposición de ratificar el acuerdo bajó
mucho el perfil y no hizo la gestión que
debía ser para la ratificación en el
congreso bueno y es previsible que el
texto sea aprobado por la cámara para
luego ser firmado por el nuevo
presidente gustavo petro que se
posiciona el 7 de agosto
si es muy probable porque el presidente
electo ya ha manifestado el interés de
firmarlo adicionalmente el congreso que
se posesionó el 20 de julio la semana
pasada ya es un congreso mucho más
progresista que entiende las
preocupaciones que tienen las
comunidades en los territorios y que
está interesado en que ese acuerdo se
firme en la cámara del balance es un
poco diferente pero también sigue
habiendo más mayorías progresistas que
apoyan esta nueva administración que se
posiciona en 7 de agosto entonces es muy
probable que se dé la ratificación en la
cámara baja en la cámara de
representantes en los próximos debates
que se vienen que sería el tercero en la
comisión segunda cámara y en la plenaria
de cámara y ya con eso faltaría el
análisis constitucional de la corte
constitucional
la firma por parte del presidente que
sería enviada a la secretaría del
acuerdo